what's up it's sassy santana latest on
the [ __ ] block check me out on
a bootleg cab podcast
bootleg cab show we got a special guest
in here fresh from rolling loud weekend
i saw you on stage doing your thing you
know what i'm saying saucy santana is in
the building
what's that what's up what is going on
outside never inside you are outside for
sure i see you everywhere yeah well
congrats on the freshman cover thank you
that was dope i like that gay boy to do
it yeah salute to that you know what i'm
saying breaking down barriers you know
what i mean that's a big deal yeah do
you feel like uh the homophobia and
hip-hop starting to fade away a little
bit yeah i feel like gay is regular like
kind of like now even when you watch
your when you watch tv games everywhere
it's almost on
every tv show is something gay every
every thing that you like you know i'm
saying
it it's just like it's becoming normal
it's becoming normal so i think people
are just kind of like
it is what it is yeah i've gotten into
arguments with people who are like you
know
you know shout out to guy like boozy
who's obviously says some offensive
things at times but i feel like
you know there's like this misconception
that like
watching a
buzz lightyear and there being a
same-sex kiss can make kids gay and i'm
like yo this is like people are born
this way this isn't like something like
45 years in a life you just decide man
i've been watching a lot of will and
grace
so i'm going to go dip my toe into that
pony how do you feel about like just
that um i don't think that i don't
necessarily think that watching that
kind of stuff i mean you know for me i
feel like kids are sensitive so i get
the argument um of it because there's
certain things that i don't let my
little sister watch at certain things i
don't let my god kids um you know be a
part of you wouldn't but you also
wouldn't let them watch like straight
people like doing crazy [ __ ] yeah you're
not gonna you're not gonna watch no
adult movies right you're not gonna
watch you know i'm seeing you know
people having sex on tv like it's
everything i just i'm just i'm gonna
sense you as a child i'm not gonna
necessarily make it about
um you know sex i even or you know gay
things on this movie i even have
um a lot of cousins like i grew up with
a lot of my cousins that are my age and
grew up like brother and sister so i
called their sons my nephews um they my
nephews they see me uh nails lashes
purse all that and they like you know of
course
okay he's different but you know i'm
still outside with him we playing
football i'm still you know what i'm
saying we playing baseball i'm like hey
you know you're a boy you don't do that
like you know what i'm saying so it's
just like they don't just because they
see me that'll mean like oh you know
uncle santana got nails on that's what
i'ma do you still a boy you still doing
your thing so you can't really try to
pin that on kids like oh they seeing
this that's what they're gonna do right
how old were you when you came out
seventeen seventeen that's that's pretty
like deep in high school years yep
seventeen i was uh
junior junior high school
came out was it like pretty evident that
you were like yeah you know what i mean
i mean like you know you kind of see
that growing up and different things
like that but just at 17 i was like man
i've been i graduated high school at 17
so i was like man i'm gonna graduate so
you were super smart like i'm outside
yeah you were getting ahead on credits
well no um my birthday is in october oh
you had one of those weird birthdays
yeah we're a birthday so i was 17.
everybody was 18 when we graduated i
couldn't even go to the club yet yeah
there's 18 up clubs in florida gotta be
crazy oh man
nothing like a florida strip club
nothing like it the office oh my god in
miami great place small place but a
great place a great place it's a great
place they got good food there too
not as good as tootsies oh what's your
name i took these that fried lobster
table with the seafood rice yes that was
a big thing that was what tootsie was
tootsie's enough for people are not
really that messed up about it i'm not
[ __ ] up about it no more but that was
the big thing to get that five likes to
tell from sixties also like
lightweight tootsies is a brothel yeah
it's you
you got a sister they catch a vibe if
you wanna see you go to you can go to
catch a vibe have some good food get a
massage and also maybe catch a virus
yeah for sure
i'll be careful on the vibrancy yeah
there's a lot going on right now [ __ ]
monkey pox you see the video of this guy
on the internet with monkeybox nah but
i've been hearing a lot about monkey
pops so i'll just be like
i'll be keeping my diseases like move
yeah that's what i mean but they like
it's a pencil to touch people right now
yeah i don't know it's it's it's wild i
mean but you know i feel like uh you
just got off a tour with lotto not too
long ago uh you've been doing some
festivals obviously rolling loud's a big
look like
are you finally you feel like you're
kind of coming into your own as a
performer
uh yeah performing for me was always
easy that was the easiest [ __ ] to do you
know the stage it turned the [ __ ] up
yeah so um ever since i speak like you
know started getting popping and started
booking shows and stuff like that um
performing was easy i think i'm coming
more to a performer now because now i
don't do clubs i do a lot of festivals
right um i do a lot of big productions i
might do jimmy fallon so huge it's huge
so it's like it's different from
in the club wrapping like four little
songs right quick to now you gotta have
dancers and everybody gotta hit this
steps at the same time and you gotta i
went from having to entertain a thousand
people in the club said it wrong allowed
gotta
you know
and it's hey thirty thousand people in
the crowd you're like
yeah and you're also entertaining a
bunch of people who like just saw you
for the first time
you know you got it you got it so it's
like you really gotta put on the show
cause i always wanted even people that
didn't know me to go home like who was
that i like him
this booty record with lotto is this
record you guys did on tour before tour
after tour um booty was at the tour
after tour so you guys kind of linked up
on the tour i'm assuming
became friend refrence prior no friends
pride me a lot have been friends since
19 2019 when we first started oh [ __ ]
okay yeah we were assigned to the same
um label stream cut it was an
independent label we were signing it
together and then she went to rca and
now i'm rca too so you're both label
mates again yep there it is uh so did
you like come up in the like rap scene
in florida or did you like have to go to
atlanta or like no i um my [ __ ] just
went viral um after i released welcome
like a dog july 4th 2019 on soundcloud
it did a million plays in seven days and
it was over [ __ ] my life changed ever
since then would you say when you did
that record you would like had any
intention to take music seriously no
never i never dreamed of being a rapper
i never wrote poems i never did any of
that [ __ ] my dad used to write when i
was a kid but i always even going
through high school all of my friends
used to rap like my homeboys in high
school used to rap i just always be like
get out of here like you're not going to
be a rapper you got to be little wayne a
[ __ ] drink of somebody what happened
like this yeah there's nobody who like
looked like you that was doing it
to be fair i also think you're the first
person i know little nazix is gay yeah
but i feel like
you're like
you're flamboyant yes in a different way
is that is that appropriate to say yes
yeah it's cool because you know when
little knives when we first met little
knives you know he was he we didn't know
he was uh he didn't know yeah we didn't
know he was we just he just had the
[ __ ] cowboy record yeah yeah
i'm saying i think i'm the first one
that came out like you know what you see
is what you get you already know what
time it is you know when you see me
and um to be able to have the amount of
success that i have being like that you
know it's new it's different it's dope
what up we gotta interrupt the interview
real quick to tell you about our people
at blue chew don't forget to go to
bluetooth.com
use the promo code bootleg right now and
get your first month free all you gotta
do is pay five dollars in shipping it's
the uh man fellas the game changer
that's all i'm gonna say
you pop the blue chew and your dick is
on a million
man i'm not saying it makes it bigger
but it feels bigger i'm just saying i'm
not saying but i'm saying
uh look same active ingredient asialis
and viagra
minus the awkward visits to the doctor's
office all right it's all over the phone
it's so easy they ship it right to your
door in discrete packaging
uh i don't know if you're going through
erectile dysfunction because you're
stressed out at work uh maybe uh you
just need a little extra hump with wifey
whatever it is maybe you just want to
take a bluetooth and beat your dick like
it stole something just to feel like
damn that shit's hard bruh you know what
i'm saying go to bluetooth.com use the
promo code bootleg right now and you
will save uh all money it's free yeah
you'll you'll get a whole month for free
bluechew.com promo code bootleg for a
whole month for free delivered to your
door discreetly no doctor's appointments
no awkward visits same viagra cialis
ingredients
man what are you waiting for go do that
do you have let me let me let's figure i
i'm curious like the type of groupies
everyone gets groupies when you have
this type of fame
what are your groupies like
um i got all kind of groupies i got like
weirdos
um i got uh
different [ __ ] trying to talk to me
you got a girl just says i'm pregnant
she's pregnant with my baby like wow a
girl said that yeah she was like i've
seen some like blog [ __ ] like some girl
says i'm she pregnant with my kid did
you ever uh did you ever dabble in
females do you ever sleep with a woman
uh-huh um um uh during like high school
so in high school you were banging i had
[ __ ]
um and so i only ever had sex with like
one girl like ever in my life okay
adjusted me like let me try justice
league let's give it a shot maybe i'm
tripping yeah like let me see it was it
was right now it was cool it was fun
it was fun
but it wasn't fun enough for you to keep
going
to keep going it was like okay like you
know
i see i see what you got going on you
know what i'm saying that's a macaroni
fan
[Laughter]
this was in high school yeah i was out
of high school already i was out of high
school shout out to you mm-hmm damn i
feel like you know i feel like we're
kind of getting to the point where like
you know
i think 15 20 years from now just like
everyone's gonna be [ __ ] everybody
like yeah i feel like it's going there
yo i know man gay boys that that was
like [ __ ] girls i know matt like a
lot of a lot of [ __ ] that i talk to
like got kids um from like you know
previous relationships yeah being in
high school and still being down though
and still [ __ ] girls that kind of
like you know
hey i'm not gay like so i don't talk to
i don't talk to a
few [ __ ] they got kids that's
interesting their kids be like 9 10
years old
like they was [ __ ] you know girls in
high school girls get pregnant you know
[ __ ] got kids
how do you feel like because i feel like
we've we've had a couple of teaching
moments in the last year in terms of
just like
you know what happened with the baby
last year running loud like i feel like
uh sometimes
we're very quick to like [ __ ] on
somebody as opposed to like trying to
like
teach them this new castle culture or
cancel culture [ __ ] it's like
trolling is is a trend now so now the
world is different back then you had to
like like
you you wasn't making no blogs like we
had to reach it in magazines or you know
what i'm saying or [ __ ] myspace my
sister it was hard now now you get on in
there and customize yours back out we on
the show
in three in three seconds and three
seconds or you can retweet my picture
and say something say something some
dumb [ __ ] or some bible [ __ ] it go bible
you all over the blog so now people are
feeling like you know what i'm saying
not to say that fans understand but just
something like they're important yeah
like so they're like oh [ __ ] i know
everyone feel like they got an opinion
that's better yeah i feel like y'all got
leverage like people like to feel like
they got you by the bars like oh you
said this say sorry
ain't gonna never let's see i'm using
them on you can't never come back
outside like suck a dick like [ __ ] are
y'all talking about literally literally
like you know it's like because people
are not doing things now because they
actually care people are doing things
now because like because they're gonna
get attention they're gonna get
attention like i got the top comment or
oh a hundred people say it down like
this blue hat so we don't [ __ ] with the
blue head cuz 100 people said it in the
comments we're just gonna be
bandwagoners i also feel like with a lot
of the cancer culture [ __ ] like just in
general like most of the time it's like
a very small amount of people who are on
twitter dumb people like when you meet
people in real life i swear to god i
just said this it's like yo most real
people don't give a [ __ ] about
this i just said it's the small minority
who are dumb saying the cancer culture
is in a [ __ ] comments it's in
the internet when you meet people in
real life you'll be like i'd be like
well where's all the [ __ ] there
hey because people they try to come at
you for old tweets yeah which was crazy
they do that to everybody everybody and
it's like my thing is my thing is i'm
not a i'm a realistic person i'm not a
fake person yeah like everybody now is
like
oh my god i can't believe you said this
in 2011
bro if you wasn't famous if the same
people that's finding our own sweets if
they wasn't famous let's go and your
twitter and see what the [ __ ] was you
saying also what are you doing with your
life where you're digging through
someone's timeline back to two you know
when they do it they do it when
you're about to reach like some type of
accomplishment or something and that's
why i said people now know that i could
go dig up a tweet and i could make this
go viral and i could have you would be
in the laughingstock or the talk of the
whole world right now because we people
it's it's set up to now where like
[ __ ] got you by the balls like oh i
could go find his old tweet saying we
he's gonna get cancelled we're gonna and
he's gonna have to sit down and
apologize like they feel like they got
some kind of power over you now so it's
not it's people's drugs it's like they
get a dopamine hit yeah when they come
for people and it works and it works and
it's like but you know you have so many
people in the world like
bro somebody said [ __ ]
10 years ago that's why i love that car
to be sued i mean listen i don't know
that blogger you know what i'm saying
but i love the fact that
cardi b won that lawsuit yeah because
that blogger was saying some [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah and it's like yo hopefully this
kind of helps correct and people you
know people believe love the negative
narrative of things that's what's best
that's what's more better or fun to
believe from them so when you're saying
wow [ __ ] about people or like you know
what i'm saying even when people are
digging up these old tweets
and
we do these pr apologies that your name
will make you do of course and all that
guess what people still say
[ __ ] you will believe you of course all
right oh we don't care you you say that
you meant it
so just be like whatever but i go
through comments and i see those people
the logical people that really is like
bro somebody said some [ __ ] 10 years ago
who gives a [ __ ] ten years ago was when
you had to have a bible tweet
well also ten years ago getting
cancelled wasn't a thing it wasn't a
thing it was like i'm gonna just say
some ill [ __ ]
you got on twitter and talk [ __ ] you got
on twitter you watch award shows or you
watch whatever the [ __ ] are you just
saying wow crazy [ __ ] because back then
you really had to have a good tweet well
you know what that i mean
it's crazy too because they just tried
to do that with gloria and i was like yo
like she just signed a crazy deal i told
you when you're reaching yeah it's like
whenever you do an accomplishment they
come right they come like oh you don't
even like y'all got them like
so what 10 years ago she probably didn't
who gives a [ __ ] she didn't know yo
gotti she didn't she was a fan she was a
she was a music consumer
voicing her opinion voice to her opinion
and then fi but you know what be so
crazy about them old sweets
they will only dig up the negative ones
ten years ago she probably could have
said [ __ ] yo gotti and then seven years
later she probably said yo gotti the
hardest rapper out right now some [ __ ]
but they're not gonna show you that part
they gonna show you that hey she said
[ __ ] yo got it 10 years ago and it's
crazy let me i got to ask you a question
i use paws a lot
do you know what that means yeah
is that homophobic no okay not to me
okay i gotta ask
if my guy's like yo man uh yo i need
extra meat on my sandwich
i just want to make sure
it's not it's not um just one thing
about gays gays are sometimes we're all
extra extra sensitive right um because
you know
just how we looked at a lot of stuff you
know gays are kind of you know thrown to
the wayside i consider you know bottom
of the barrel um
of things or you know even when we're
dealing with you know men we consider
like you know
soft or you know different things like
that so gays is always on a defense
but that's not uh that's not to me
that's not that's not offensive that's
not offensive oh no gotta make sure man
you calling me something crazy outside
my name is offensive but the pause is
possible yeah that's cool it's cool okay
but you guys gotta make sure you gotta
get because i'll be pausing a lot now i
mean
i'll say that like i don't actually i'm
like yo that's me and my brother me and
my brother uh trey tracks my producer
like if i would have been like i want an
extra minute he would have been like hey
yo like oh
pause like hey what
oh i could be like with my [ __ ] son and
my [ __ ] like put his arm around my
shoulder my brother's gonna be like hey
yo like that's our pause
so nice so you're taken
yeah currently currently
how long have you been in a relationship
um my [ __ ] actually just spitting the
blocks off
um
he just spent the block he just spent a
lot what's that mean um i mean i know
what spin in the block means but like in
context to a relationship
well you know we we was in a
relationship last year you know we broke
up and he came back around
the block
i hop right back in the car oh shout out
to him and you came back in yeah salute
i mean yo yeah i mean maybe you saw he's
just i almost just feed you i'm sorry
jesus christ uh you're on the freshman
cover yeah things are going well yeah
maybe i need to come back around before
this year but you know the reason why i
really [ __ ] with him though because he
ain't he like you know i said of course
he does his accomplishment stuff but
like he just really a real [ __ ] like
that that don't that don't make or break
me his relationship like you know what
i'm saying and i'm i'm i'm very
observant so i watch things like that
like you got to watch my [ __ ] just
like
oh yeah he lit like damn he more late
than last year like like and they're
gonna ask you know nothing from me like
you know he a good dude what's um what
is a
romantic gesture that that you have in
your pocket like like give me like a
romantic gesture that you you go to in a
relationship
i know he says i'm not i'm not really
like with my wife i'll buy her flowers
it'll be like 11 roses i totally stole
this from the internet yeah
and one white rose in the middle and
i'll leave her a letter and i'll be like
you represent the right white rose
because you're different than everybody
else
uh what's that it's so funny he says
that i'm not romantic um he's more the
romantic one like that [ __ ] just bought
me two thousand dollars worth of flowers
and i was mad at [ __ ] like that's a lot
of flowers yes but like i'd be mad too
if my girl i'd be like hey we could have
bought hello i could have got a new pair
of shoes or something i could have got 4
000 tacos from jack in the box
so he made romantic me i'm more
thoughtful so like um his dad passed um
when he was a kid and uh it just
um the anniversary of the deaf hat came
up and so i had just like seen him out
when i was like hey go get some flowers
and balloons you know the texas to the
ground feel dead oh wow so i'm
thoughtful i think i'm
yo who like growing up listening to
music who's like on your music mount
rushmore gucci mane that's my favorite
rapper gucci gucci is probably the most
i mean arguably most influential guy
best a r in hip-hop history he's got the
best year i think ever
so gucci mane's on there you got three
more slots to fill um trainer
shout out to the baddest [ __ ] jackie ow
jackie o does not get enough love they
don't
oh i lived in tampa for a few years but
i'm from phoenix but i know jackie yeah
because i'm saying jackie hill is a
florida thing yeah yeah yeah jackie
jackie out and uh
two more uh
nicki minaj once you know we got in high
school nikki had all of us acting like
barbies especially with me
were you kind of a barb of course okay
well i mean i had to i was still like in
high school i was still like in the
closet so i made all of my homegirls
like everybody had a dress like nicki
and i started as a group it was called
ken in the dolls i was kid and they was
the dolls so you made them all dressed
like how you kind of wanted a dress yeah
i'm living through y'all so you got to
get the nicki minaj bang with the black
and pink hair like i mean all of them
dressed like barbies [ __ ] was so funny
um are you still a barb yeah okay i love
nicki stella bart um
who else i listen to growing up yeah one
more
we got nikki jackie oh and uh and gucci
those are those are that's that's three
good ones uh future future
future the greatest club artist of all
time
i remember when future one thing i love
about gucci gucci brought out future
migos all the [ __ ] like all them
people
all in there listening to gucci was
throwing them on features way back in
the days when we didn't even know who
they was
people don't know like uh even like
somebody like the amigos like yes he
could have signed them if you wanted to
yes gucci that's how i got introduced to
amigos yeah i remember they always be on
sons of gucci yeah are you currently
like in atlanta are you still in florida
where are you at yeah i live in atlanta
how is atlanta like i've been there i
love it there by the way it's great
atlanta
i went during the uh pandemic and it was
you know from one thing i love the
valentina we we ain't do we didn't
believe in the fandom exactly that's why
i liked it everybody came in the car
covered and went back home because i
i've been i've been in i was i was in
l.a going crazy and we went to atlanta
for like a week and i was like this this
is this is different atlanta was lit
everything was open a script club
everything no masks no nothing like we
was outside
it was so funny i was like oh my god
this is the only place in the world
that's outside it was amazing
it was lit
um but you know i feel like i'll grow
that in a little bit i'm fine to move to
l.a l.a well be prepared if a pandemic
comes back your ass is going to be
mashed up oh trust me don't think i
ain't keeping my crib in atlanta
i'll be gone
so you might be moving to l.a everyone
moves to l.a yeah i'ma come out here i
got a lot of work here you know i travel
with a big team my security go
everywhere with me you know my role
manager uh my other manager my my
brother who is my dj producer my
cameraman is like i got a crew that's a
lot yeah so that's a lot you know
dancers dancers all that so it's a lot
bringing everybody with you getting all
these different hotels oh it's a lot for
sure and then you know
it'd be like a lot of it's a lot of
opportunity that's how i feel like when
i first moved to atlanta it was an
opportunity to me and the artist i was
there now now all of my opportunities
are here and you know you bro i feel
like you broke through and i feel like
once you break through like you at least
got to be in l.a a little bit more yeah
you got to because you know stuff is
sparta mommy here so you might you might
have somebody hit you and be like yo i'm
in the studio
in the studio she said i pull up i'm
like oh i could be that first thing in
the morning uh exactly i gotta fly out
to saudi arabia this is literally what i
tell every artist that's like
i got an artist who's from who lives in
missouri
and he was in la for a little bit but he
couldn't afford to stay out here and i
was like figure it out because there's
opportunities like that pop up last
minute yes you're going to be [ __ ] out
of those you're going to be because like
right now you want to buy people and be
in the vibe in the moment and then they
got might got a flight the next day and
that's like all right i'm gonna spin the
block on you and yeah
never ever happens i swear to god nikki
dm me one time and was like you went la
i was like no i'm in atlanta but i could
come i could get there she was like oh
okay i'm like dang i wonder why she
asked me because she lives here yeah she
lived here
i knew that sound like dang i wanna
watch nicki dm you yeah so
did you get i would have been like i'm
in la
i wasn't though so i couldn't lie like
[ __ ] that i'd be like where's the
airport take me to the airport yeah but
it's like now they're outside man she
like pull up now it's like yeah i'll be
there in four and a half hours
we gotta figure that [ __ ] out yeah so it
was like i was like dang bro hey what
you gotta do is when you finally get
your house
go back to the dms and say
hey heads up i live here now i live here
uh-huh for show and then just send her
this clip yeah you say you were a barb
and you had a whole rap group oh nick no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
did she know that you had the high
school group yes nikki like nikki know
everything in the dolls yes nicki no
like me and nikki is like this like
she's the goat she's the greatest female
rapper of all time yeah for
tell me
obviously we're in la west hollywood is
a pop in gay area the clubs there are
insane if you like drive in that area
it's like trust me i think i had to
perform at we have right oh how was it
it was lit
what's the what's the better you've seen
partying gay clubs here atlanta
i feel like they're way different
atlanta
but i'm not really heavy in gay clubs
like party scene i like strip clubs so
you rather go to the strip club yes i
love cheetahs cheetahs out here yes she
just is solid
it is a good one
yeah ball and cheetahs
strip club no uh they're probably gross
right yeah i don't like that i like i
like bbs you like the bbos
nice shout out to the bbls i feel yo
i was in uh the the dominican republic
and we were flying back and there was at
least four women on the plane that were
like on wheelchairs
huh going over there to get that body
snatched up i said [ __ ] the show i said
at least hang out out here for like a
week and and and let the swelling go
down no baby
gone are dudes getting bbl's i just saw
a banmo uh bandman kevo got his body
done uh-huh dudes get well gay boys get
bbl's now dudes so get your teammate gay
guys to get the fake ass yeah you've
seen this i got one you got a bbl
your cheeks are
is it a fat reassignment what is going
on back there they just take it they
just take it from your stomach in your
waist and just put it in the back put it
in your ass and hips so you got the bbo
popping
where'd you go to get it down
miami was it painful nah
wow it's not
it's really not like you just wake up
you kind of soar a little bit and then
like you can't sit on your butt for like
uh four to six weeks i broke my tailbone
when i was in uh elementary school and i
had to sit on a donut uh-huh yeah that's
the thing they like a little you get
like a little doughnut or they get like
a little um
a little um thing that's like you could
sit but your butt doesn't sit on the
seat whenever you're sitting down well
yeah i saw you uh twerking on stage uh
unapologetically as you should uh at
rolling out
and i was like [ __ ] man dude's got
cheeks pause you know i mean dude's got
some cheeks though
so so at least we know now that you
wouldn't got them things situated uh-huh
enough for sure but most men like
surgery is so
normal now of course [ __ ] just going
to get abs and getting they sucked down
and all kind of stuff for sure i just um
saw you know we do a radio show every
day so
obviously you know the hollywood unlocks
and shade rooms
there's this there's like a dick surgery
now where you can like get your dick
extended for real yeah i can't even
imagine how crazy it would be i remember
they had the dick pump
oh yeah that's from like the 90s for
real my uncle had one i tried one three
yeah i had one yeah how does it work
when i was like 19 when me and my baby
mama went to the porn store for the
first time i was like let me try this
thing
does it really work i mean for a second
oh [ __ ] that's crazy
it's it's like it just sucks your dick
like pause
[Laughter]
it like you like pump it you like pump
it and then like your dick gets bigger
in this tube and then like you take it
off it's not comfortable
but i only did it once i was a kid yeah
but yeah definitely not i wouldn't
suggest that i wouldn't suggest getting
this done
getting the surgery
how about you just you got what you got
yes work with what you got work with you
with what you got for sure it's a size
matter
not to me not to you there it is i don't
know you know your perspective some
ladies would say
it doesn't matter
yeah about the motion of the ocean young
miami will say it matters she would say
it matters
she's dating diddy-ish
yeah yeah
she ish it's no it's really she she
really does
she does date him um she's got a great
show huh i love her new show yes i heard
kareesha please it's so good yeah they
confirmed it you know on the show that
that day i saw that and then i just
started twerking on cueva and rolling
loud so we entertainers we rappers for
sure and we outside
so just cause you dating somebody like
you know what i'm saying they not
married
they already said i'm dating this person
i'm dating this person but [ __ ] we
outside hey we gotta stop the interview
real quick to tell you about our
partners our family at odd socks go to
oddssoxofficial.com
right now
and the promo code bootleg kev it'll get
you 20 off the fly of socks in the world
[ __ ] spongebob
[ __ ] cheez-its
a little bit of pepsi
uh how about how about some underwear do
we like underwear e.t boxers let's go
ahead and just open up a pair of these
boys
so you can see how fly the draws are
ladies and gentlemen because they are
fly by the way they just gave me my own
pair of odd socks go on my social media
and you can see him uh i don't know if
they're going to be for sale
because let's be honest
who wants to wear socks with my [ __ ]
ugly face on them besides my wife and
she don't even want to wear them there
we go
they got the draws they got it all man
get the odd socks basics which i love
just the basic boys these are amazing
comfy socks on socksofficial.com use the
promo code bootleg kev save 20 off let's
get back to the interview have you had
any famous guys slide in your dms like
on the low ski broski like uh yeah but i
don't get into that no you're not going
to tell us who it is i wouldn't expect
you to yeah that's the people business
but hell yeah [ __ ] is yeah hottest
hand
that's i mean man listen you're a very
successful artist the music is dope the
booty record is going up you haven't
dropped an album in a couple of years so
when is is this out
yeah that's what we right now we're in a
creative process i'm figuring out you
know what i'm saying like you know i
have a lot of new fans now so i want to
you know explore new styles and stuff
you know reaching out to just everybody
but still staying true to myself still
staying true to my fans and what they
want to hear so we're just going through
the creative process figuring out which
artists sound good on what records and
different things like that how many
records you're sitting on right now
i got so many damn songs that's all i do
they the phone is ringing right now they
want me to come to the [ __ ] studio
when i finish this so every time i'm in
la we in the studio you're working
non-stop are you uh are you the type of
person who has to write their own [ __ ]
do you get help with the writing are you
open to both things i'm up in the boat
now i'm opening the boat when i started
seeing our favorite [ __ ] songs
that we think somebody works so hard on
and all that and when you gonna read the
credits and it's like eight seven people
[ __ ] with him we love it like you wrote
it we don't give a [ __ ] so now i just
had to grow to that because once i had
first started rapping i felt like i had
so much to prove
and i felt like i was a new rapper and i
was gay i was like my first
three
projects you wrote it all i wrote it all
i wrote it all
um
my next hit um we just did a song i feel
good when i was in atlanta me and my
brother trey tracks i wrote the whole
song wow
feature on it material girl i wrote the
whole song that's that's your biggest
record right yes yeah um material got
about that whole one sire song top to
bottom so it's like um
i just but i just realized now with like
in music
everybody like this oh i'm not a rap
okay you can know how to rap you know
what i'm saying but you know a hit is a
hit were you nervous to do your freshman
freestyle
hell yeah all of us was yeah when you
gotta do freshmen
you go there that morning first of all
all of us have to agree on the beat okay
so everyone's gotta be like yes
everyone's gotta be like yes and if you
ask don't say yes and you get
outnumbered yes grass okay so we all
have to agree on to be
that morning you have to do a freestyle
a cipher so those are already two wraps
two different wraps
um
they have an abc segment they have a
read read hateful comments segment long
days i have to do photo shoots so it's a
long goddamn day
type of me i get ready like a girl so i
have to get glam makeup done all that
[ __ ] um you go do your
different you gotta have like three four
outfits different photo shoots and all
that so you're doing photo shoots
throughout the day different content
pieces and trying to write two raps that
you got a goddamn remember right and you
gotta kill it and you gotta kill it yeah
so it's like you kind of you kind of
write you got to recite a rap like
if alice if i listen to my favorite song
10 times i could rap it better that 10th
time then when the first time i heard it
so it's like you kind of got to go out
there and wrap your [ __ ] with confidence
like you popping your [ __ ] knowing them
wearing your hair you don't even got to
ever remember the lyrics cause you just
wrote that [ __ ] right and you gotta
remember too you gotta remember your
freestyle and you gotta remember
decipher yeah
crazy who are you in the cipher with it
was me douchey dolce is dope as hell
incredible shout out to tampa
um
[ __ ] casey
casey
from new york i think from jersey
somewhere up there and i forgot the
other boy name
were you um like
thanks so much
sometimes we hear stories people do the
freshman shoot and then collaborations
end up happening after because you hang
out with them all day was there anybody
who you linked up with who you kind of
caught a vibe with there douchey douchey
she's incredible she bought tampa yeah
shut up so funny because i always i
looked at dolce is like a pop like kind
of poppy and then we was at the thing
she was like i said i put the ass out i
was like ooh florida you from florida
that's florida what's that's house
yes host of florida
and you're gonna say [ __ ] you gotta say
is is i know jit's a florida thing but
is jit like tallahassee a florida thing
like what's that does it get i'm saying
does it get up to tallahassee because i
know it's like heavy like in the tampa
area yeah
what's up g whatever we call ikea is
that that's my jig
tallahassee also uh
t-paints from there yeah um you should
link with talent
have you met t-pain yet i never met
steve hank you actually do a song
together but we but we know he froze
tallahassee yeah you got to do it he and
he lives in atlanta hey get me out with
us he can't produce a song which one i
wouldn't produce the song for me yeah
don't give me t-pain pizza you wouldn't
let him you wouldn't let him do a hook
you're saying no to the t-pain don't see
me produce the songs even write the song
for me creative diaries and knowledge
you won't let him be on the hook
it's t-pain it's t-pain okay
she's like i don't give a [ __ ] like
producer's huh like who got a song with
t.k
but i think that tv some people are like
behind the scenes kind of people like i
feel like t-pain had a long-ass run she
painted millions of records so i know
that he just had a top five song at
radio about six months ago who what song
t-pain just had okay lonnie it's called
i like that
i got i never heard it it's uh
it was t-pain featuring kailani it was
like number it was it hit number two at
rhythm
you heard it yeah i only said this
because i i yeah yeah
are you making are you telling us he
definitely heard the [ __ ] record
yeah anyway
we got to hear it yeah anyway how you
guys seeing it i liked it
nothing drank she got money in the bank
what you think about that it's what uh
it's with kelani
[Music]
write my song and produce it there it is
right my song we gotta get nikki on the
record with you i gotta get nikki on
yeah you gotta make that happen
you already got lotto no big lotto any
other biggies any other features that
like what about trina gucci mane yes
trina
i want to do i want to do i want to do a
song with trina for the culture um you
know people who are kind of outside of
like uh
like trina is like really big in the gay
community yeah she is she's [ __ ] lit
yes legendary and they come in legends
and for me i want to do i want to do a
song with trinity because me growing up
like even though i i'm originally from
up north and i remember like you know
how the difference between living on
earth and living down south i really was
older like from being ten to all the way
my whole adulthood was florida so trina
was my little kim yeah when you grew up
north they had little kim is what you
know trina was running [ __ ] yeah but
down south we had trina trina the mother
of miami yeah so i just feel like you
know a lot of my music is florida based
i would consider myself like you know
florida girl florida water because
that's a lot of the stuff that i grew up
on when i was a kid when i lived up
north southeastern university florida's
a wild place yeah i was listening to pop
music when i was like britney spears and
[ __ ] i was a kid shout out to brittany
so that's what was on like going to
school trl and all that 106 apart a
little bit on [ __ ] like this shout out
to bow wow
that was a ran 106 in park i feel like
he owned when i was a kid i thought he
owned bt yeah because i was like god
damn this one i could love that
host of 106 and park every week his
video is always number one yeah even the
[ __ ] that sucked
jesus uh so album on the way you're
working on it the new single is out
featuring lotto yeah uh anything else
you're getting into any acting any tv
stuff on tour with lizzo you and lizzle
going on tour shout out to lizzo shout
out to the [ __ ] that's huge
she's wildly talented um mia madonna
song mysterio girl remix spot to come
out you got a song with madonna yes of
course i didn't know that
we did a material remix um we performed
it and and i performed it with her new
york pride
was she cool
like a [ __ ] rock star madonna is so
cool and so lit and madonna is a boss i
mean she's [ __ ] like she's a [ __ ]
queen do you ask her questions like
about like some of like like the 80s and
[ __ ] i'd be like yo like i was i would
have i just you know bomb you i'm like
yo how was dennis rodman was it good
like no it was so funny like i just like
it was just being right how you just bad
like
we like in the studio she like i think i
want to rock our d should i say that i
was like oh [ __ ] like madonna said that
yeah yeah it was it was something it was
it was we was doing the reviews and she
was like
something something i want a rock hard
dick and i just bust that off i was like
oh [ __ ] like this lady is literally
telling she was like should i say that i
was like i feel like she i feel like
she's definitely going through like a
patch in life where she's like on her
young girl [ __ ] again i love i love
madonna um she loves peppermint um
steamer so you have whatever room she's
in you have to have a peppermint it has
to smell like peppermint ah
um i know how she smells i don't know
what it is she smells good if i smell it
i'll be like madonna smell like that i
can remember out of thought i forgot the
name um she's cool as [ __ ] and she
worked hard as hell like
us going to rehearsals together like
madonna coming in rehearsal with heels
on and long as blonde hair and her
makeup done i'm like with her little
outfits i'm like this lady's still a
[ __ ] rock star
it was like it was an experience shout
out to madonna that's a big deal no not
a lot of barely anyone has records
that's what i said i was like yo you
know i know people have been rapping for
so long
jay-z might be the last person who had a
madonna feature quavo oh was it cuevo
see i didn't i didn't know champagne
champagne rose didn't hear that one
mm-hmm sure was that on cueva solo album
yeah not the best album so probably
passed away that's probably
what was saying yeah i remember that
song um you have to say i'm like i had
to i had to sit down and think i'm like
you know how many people been rapping
for so long you never even
got to even chance to smell madonna and
i was right there
[ __ ] is crazy shout out to madonna
that's what's up she goes by m now it's
still funny she doesn't got my mama down
this m you're gonna call her m mm-hmm
that's interesting what we wear is like
m you know you're famous if you could
just go buy a letter she got a big m
ring nobody calls our madonna i felt so
stupid i was like um
i don't know if i could call another
human m if i know if you're madonna i'm
like you're madonna that's how i'm
saying but it's like everybody's like m
you're kind of late in the game and once
a donut m's ready to leave m says you
can come in now
oh [ __ ] i bet she's she she probably
moves that way right yeah
no jokes did i need my peppermint
steamer in the studio
like this is what we're doing
i i need this kind of water yes don't
[ __ ] with me
[ __ ] with m [ __ ] i'm madonna that's
fire
there it is i can't wait to be like that
well listen man i appreciate you coming
through thanks for having me last
question if you could if there was any
girl in the world who who's so fine that
it's made you think about like [ __ ] i
don't know about this gay [ __ ] which
which one is it yeah miami young miami i
respect that
oh yeah good choice good choice shout
out to young miami
there it is saucy santana in the
building oolet kev show